and finally new rules someone has to
break it to the world's religions that
they have something in common with adi
the new female sex pill yes that's right
there's now a pill that makes women want
more sex but can also lower blood
pressure and put you to sleep it it was
invented by Bill Cosby
I know what you're asking bill what
could a female sex pill possibly have in
common with religion well both try to
tell you that your sexual urges as you
feel them are just not right Anita
justment people have been calling adi
the female viagra but no Adi is a mood
drug
whereas viagra is for men who still have
the desire for sex but physically can't
their penis used to go up like a
lightsaber and now it goes on like
hanging Christmas lights
viagra simply addresses blood flow which
is why so many first-time viagra users
never refill the prescription they think
it's going to make them horny for their
wives again but they end up watching
sportscenter same as always except with
a raging hard-on which sounds bad but it
actually creates the perfect place to
stack your onion rings but addi
isn't a drug for making women able to
have sex it's to make them want to and
that's why it's so wrong it's
medicalizing a woman's natural mental
state
you're not just not in the mood the drug
company says you have sexual desire
disorder except it's not a disorder it's
the perfectly normal result of having to
wash your husband's dirty drawers every
day for the last year
but wait now that we have this pill for
women who don't want to have sex but
want to want it maybe we need a pill
maybe we need a pill for people who
don't want to take the pill but need to
be made to take it introducing
pillow-fight certified the pill that
makes you take the pill that makes you
want to wat what you don't really want
ask your doctor if pilla Phi is right
for you ask him to ask us and we'll tell
you yeah
yeah yeah we checked and he said [ __ ]
yeah it's right for you but look why
should people who aren't that into sex
be made to feel like they need
medication and conversely why should
people who want a lot of sex be made to
feel like they need a cold shower
which brings me to religion and Josh
Duggar
Josh of course is one of the 19 Duggar
children from that horrific reality show
and as a professional Christian he'd
been getting paid to preach about only
using his penis to procreate with his
God sanctioned spousal vessel and yet
Josh it turns out had not one but two
accounts on Ashley Madison and on his
profile under turn-ons
he basically listed all of the above he
was seeking tall women short women long
hair short hair girl-next-door type
naughty girl type basically anyone who
wasn't breastfeeding in a prairie dress
and he blamed his infan del infidelity
on a porn addiction Oh Josh dude you're
just horny
I'd say the genie is out of the bottle
but I'm afraid you'd bang the genie
or the bottle
Josh Duggar like lots of people just
wasn't cut out to be married isn't it a
bit weird that in a country which now
celebrates every alternative gender and
sexual choice we're still judging and
micromanaging straight sex Caitlyn
Jenner gets up at the ESPYs in a dress
with tips and a dick under it and
there's not a dry eye in the house
somehow with gay and transgender people
we celebrate as we should the concept of
I am Who I am I was born this way this
is my truth well great but could we get
the same deal for the other 95 percent
of us
if you don't want to [ __ ] your husband
fine and if you want to [ __ ] a lot of
people fine - whatever you want should
be fine because when it comes to sexual
freedom I'll have what she's having
you